what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I jumped on Twitter and I asked
you guys I said what should the next
topic for too powerful for the Marvel
Universe what should the next character
be and by and large the the biggest
response was the one above all ah which
is way too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
alright just by definition the one above
all is too powerful for the Marvel
Universe but I also recognized these
videos draw in a lot of people who were
totally unfamiliar with comics and so in
order to make you guys some more
familiar with comic books we're gonna
provide some context here and we're
gonna provide context in relation to
like some of those powerful beings in
existence rise to take Protege for
example protege is an alternate reality
character who basically had the ability
to copy the powers of others and there
was no upper limit to it so as long as
you saw someone using their abilities he
could copy them so if protege saw
Professor Charles Xavier of the x-men
using telepathy he'd be able to copy it
if protege saw magneto using his powers
he could copy it if protege saw the
molecule man Owen Reese manipulating
reality Protege could copy it it goes on
and on and on and on and presumably if
protege saw the one above all use its
power protege could copy the power of
the one above all there was no upper
limit there there are beings like the
molecule man Owen Reese who is powerful
on a multiversal scale meaning that he
could control the fundamental forces of
not just one universe but all the
universes in the multiverse and
presumably destroyed all the Beyonder is
the other half of Owen Reese they could
basically do the same thing there were
two parts of a cosmic cube you take like
the beyonders from Jonathan Hickman
offenders and New Avengers which were
not as powerful as the original Beyonder
the way the way that he originally
appeared but you take the beyonders who
were going around and wiping out like
The Living Tribunal and wiping out like
all the cosmic entities they were they
were vastly powerful every single being
that exists in Marvel Comics you could
ever look up in terms of all the power
they possess right like the chaos skiing
Gabriel Shepard Matthew Malloy all of
them pale in comparison to the power of
the one above all Thanos were the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos with a heart of
the universe all those characters pale
in comparison to the power of the one at
my wall why because the one above all is
the creator of the entire Marvel
omniverse what does that mean okay so
let's say you know Gordon my editor
Gordon you got to help me out here all
right let's say that you have a circle
alright and this circle is called six
one six
what does that mean in Marvel Comics
every universe has a numerical
designation that's how you differentiate
universes from each other so instead of
saying like the a the ultimate universe
or Age of Apocalypse or like the
universe of magic Jasper's the original
Madame Gaspar's and said Marvel uses
numerical designation so the main Marvel
Universe you go into a comic book store
right now and you buy the amazing
spider-man by Nick Spencer that takes
place in earth-616 the main Marvel
Universe on the Age of Apocalypse were
the villain apocalypse conquered North
America and intended to conquer the
world that's earth to 95 the original
madam Jasper's story that's earth to 38
the ultimate universe the universe of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is based
off of that's earth sixteen ten one six
one zero now say that this universe were
looking at you know earth-616 the main
Marvel Universe this is just a circle
now let's say inside this circle is a
series of smaller circles right one of
these smaller circles is called Asgard
another smaller circle is called Olympus
where the Greek gods dwell another
smaller universe is called the Dark
Dimension where Dormammu hangs out and
another small universe is called the
Crimson dimension which houses sit Iraq
the being that gives juggernaut his
power now these are the smaller circles
inside this earth-616 circle these are
just called like dimensions or realms
whatever you want to call them the Torah
is interchangeable small pocket
locations inside in existing universe
every single universe has its own Asgard
every single universe has its own Dark
Dimension every universe has its own
crimson dimension every universe has its
own Olympus now this circle here let's
say that you zoom out and there's a
circle next to it called earth one six
one zero the ultimate universe has its
own version of these things earth 295
earth 238 and it goes on and on and on
and on for an infinite number of
universes and let's say this infinite
number of universes is housed inside a
bigger circle and we'll put in for this
bigger circle that means multiverse it's
an infinite number of universes all of
which housed their own dimensions and so
on and so forth now this is simply just
the multiverse as you think of it in
Marvel comics like The Living Tribunal
for example it presides over that
multiverse to make sure there's no
imbalance of magical energy the one
above all created that multiverse that
multiverse exists because the one above
all made it but the one above all also
made everything else so let's say with
that bigger circle with an M on it let's
say that next to that is a bigger circle
that says DC DC Comics let's say that
the circle next to that is the universe
where friends
takes place the TV show that's the
omniverse the omniverse is every single
universe that could possibly exist
throughout the entirety of all
conceivable existence so like the main
Marvel multiverse the beyond verse the
DC Comics multiverse all that stuff you
know all that's part of the omniverse
every universe that could possibly exist
even if it's not tied into Marvel Comics
even if it has nothing to do with Marvel
Comics at all it's part of the omniverse
so like in the omniverse is like all the
stories from the TV show twilight zone
and in the omniverse is like the Star
Wars universe and in the in the
omniverse is like the Star Trek universe
you know you guys understand I'm saying
it's every possible concept that could
ever exist that exists in its own
universe or multiverse or what have you
the one above all presides over all of
that all of those things are we're
basically at least according to our
comics
created by the one above all now I say
that loosely because it's Marvel's way
of establishing the role the one above
all place if you go to DC Comics DC
comics will say it's the present if you
go to you know Image Comics it was the
beings above mal Bhoja and all those
characters from spawn depending on what
comic line you're reading they'll have
their own version of the one above all
and so you're talking about a being that
Mason created conceivably according to
Marvel Comics all things that that exist
in 80 former fashion across the entirety
of existence in every conceivable way
that's an astronomical amount of power
how does it being like Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet face off against that
danos can't but the one above all has
that much power
it's just that astronomically powerful
it's this immutable indestructible
inconceivable concept that exists in
Marvel Comics
there's no way to defeat it the
beyonders couldn't defeat it the
molecule man Owen Reese can't defeat
them what like nothing can beat the one
above all the one of them all will never
end it'll it'll never die it's just so
it's the being that you just said before
everything came into existence as the
being that will exist after everything's
destroyed and when it's all recreated in
reality you know like like looking at it
from a real world perspective you know
as you're watching this video Marvel
kind of uses the one above all is a
metaphor you know as it's kind of a
metaphor for like Marvel writers you
know whoever is writing the story or
like whoever's running Marvel Comics at
the time the one above all has appeared
as a Jack Kirby the one above all has
appeared as Stan Lee are the one above
all has appeared in a variety of
different ways in Marvel Comics the one
of them all actually showed up as a
homeless man once
to spider-man you know basically said
yeah you want me he's gonna die cuz you
know that's just kind of how things go
but the one above all has appeared
occasionally to various people but you
never see it the one above all has only
ever appeared twice in Marvel Comics and
has been referenced 15 times besides
that and that's it there's really no
reason to invoke it because nothing can
destroy it so the one who have all just
kind of it'll probably like for example
the one who've all popped up in infinity
finale by jim Starlin after the events
of secret Wars when the Living Tribunal
was killed by the beyonders and Adam
warlock from a different universe was
tasked with becoming the New Living
Tribunal that's the one of them all up
here you know in that instance the one
above all is is is more more or less a
concept so it can be a man or a woman it
could be a frog it could be a stick that
talks to you a burning bush it could be
any number of different things that are
out there it's one of those things where
because it never acts you can't really
say it's too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
because what would it do I mean if the
one above all came down and said you
know what Thanos freaking out half of
life in existence that's that's a
problem so like fix I mean like that
would be what the one above all would do
I mean assuming that it even cared
enough to come down and do anything in
the first place you know because
normally the the the things that you
would expect the one above all to step
in and take care of are things that the
Living Tribunal steps in and takes care
right litter tribunal is the judge of
the multiverse The Living Tribunal sits
around and says okay so we have cosmic
entities and all that kind of stuff my
job is to make sure there's no imbalance
of mystical energy ie magical energy so
you can't have two doctor Strange's in
the same universe or something along
those lines
the Beyonder for example the original
beyond are from secret wars in 1984 the
olivia tribunal tried to stop that
original Beyonder why because that was
an extreme amount of power that if left
unchecked would obliterate the entire
multiverse but the one above all never
acts it never needs to because you know
it's just kind of like yes I plan these
things out this happens because I want
it to all I kind of stuff like collapse
of the multiverse during Secret Wars
happen because of the one of them all
wanted it to we know that it wanted it
to because it let it happen so again
like you know it's it's things like that
there's no conceivable way to beat it
there's no conceivable way to defeat it
so if it showed up then yeah it would
just destroy everything because nobody
could stand against it no character that
can even be created even if even if the
writers just made a character up right
like even the Russo brothers just like
made up a character it couldn't defeat
the one above all because it's just not
powerful enough for me and you know it's
either that or the was defeated the what
above all would be a contradiction right
like the one above all created all
things is immutable and indestructible
so it's like the god paradox right you
know can God create an
object too heavy for him to lift if the
one above all is the crater is the the
Alpha the Omega the beginning in the end
of all things and then it's destroyed
was it ever the one above all in the
first place so like that's that's kind
of the problem that you run into that's
kind of the paradox that you run into
there but again I mean it's just an
astronomical amount of power I mean it's
it would be like like a bacteria like it
like a single-celled organism trying to
defeat Thanos with the Infinity goal is
not gonna happen there's no conceivable
way for it to take place so again I
don't know how else to explain that I
don't know how else to say that the one
above all is too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because you're
talking about a being that was powerful
enough to create the omniverse in its
entirety a space of universes that
Dwarfs the size of the main Marvel
Universe you know the main Marvel
multiverse you know it's it's just an
astronomical amount of power is just
completely immutable and destructible
nothing can defeat it so if that level
is just I mean I don't know how to make
this video compelling
it's just that damn powerful I mean it's
just it's it's nuts but I guess doing
the best we can with what we got I was a
little bad for when people asked that I
was like really the wonder why would we
do something on the one above all like
it's speaks for itself you know it's the
one above all like it's you know it's
it's weird but anyway yeah let me know
you guys steam down to the comments
section also give me ideas for the next
video I'm thinking about doing the chaos
king a monsoon mocha uh my Kobashi I
think is what it is the Cascade wiped
out like 97% of the cosmic entities and
like stole their power like we're really
not under send to the gods and like to
stole their power it almost destroyed
the entire multiverse it's kind of a
kind of bonkers because wouldn't you
think about it as powerful as a chaos
scheme was the chaos King was just an
aspect of oblivion which tells you how
powerful oblivion was so like oblivion
was not like it's it wasn't such the
idea with oblivion is that like
everything will end right like eternity
a living embodiment of the universe
infinity the living embodiment of time
that passes from the birth of the
universe to its death they will all die
and what would happen is oblivion would
basically wipe it all away like it would
absorb it into itself it would it would
wipe all those things away then the
Phoenix force would come back and create
everything new again that's that's the
role it was Capote there was supposed to
have been played the problem is the
beyonders destroyed everything
prematurely so we didn't actually get to
see that play out because there were a
lot of things we were supposed to happen
in Marvel Comics you're supposed to play
out a certain way like the natural death
of the universe Franklin Richards and
Galactus would be the last two beings
left alive to see the death of the
universe and then they would be reborn
into the new universes whatever
they took plate whatever forms it took
place but the fact remains that you know
kind of getting back on track with the
one above all yeah it's an astronomical
amount of power I mean nothing could
defeat it nothing can destroy it there's
no way for anything to possibly win
against it so whatever he said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]